Let's drill down a bit into a very simple connector, the procedural call
connector provided by all, all your friendly programming languages.
First of all there's a flow of control, that is, control is with
the calling routine and then control shifts to be with the called routine. So
that's a coordination role. There's transmission of data
via the parameters, so that's a communication role. Procedure call is so
common, so pervasive a part of programming languages that it's basis for
all of the composite connectors, that is when we make a complex connector out of
simpler connectors. For example in the Java method call we have the caller,
the callee, there's exactly one, at any given time there's exactly one caller
and one callee. So we can say the fan in is one and the fan out is one as well.
Sounds simple right, but there's all kinds of variations. For
example,. How are the parameters transmitted? Well, there's call by reference,
call by value, call by name. There could be default values,
keyword parameters, inline parameters. If there's a return value,
things could be provided by invocation records, by a hash table.
And even the order of valuation is a variant. Are the arguments which might
themselves be procedure calls, method calls evaluated left to right,
right to left or whatever. Some languages provide for multiple entry points
that is when you call a method you may enter that method in different places.
Is the invocation explicit as it would be in a method call, or is it
implicit as it might be in an object oriented line in which there's delegation,
and the ultimate callee is known specifically by the caller. Usually we think
of procedure calls as synchronous but there are also situations where procedure
calls can be asynchronous. We mentioned the possibility of different fan ins and
fan outs, okay? And then there's the issue, the variation that is allowed as far
as accessibility is concerned. We know, for example, programming languages allow
for only private access that is within the same class. Or protected access,
to the method from the particular class or it's parents, or children classes,
and then public acc, access, where any other, the caller can be anyplace